[Musique]
alors comment vous expliquez ça voyez
comment on fait un enfant un bain c'est
un peu pareil en fait on prend de liste
et on les a brick voilà voilà
et du coup ça fait une fusion
[Musique]
on est dimanche soir les résultats du
premier tour des élections de votre
commune tombe
aucune liste n'a obtenu la majorité
absolue c'est à dire plus de la moitié
des fois la loi prévoit que les listes
ayant obtenu moins de 5% des voix au
premier tour sont éliminés d'office
tandis que celles ayant remporté le plus
de 10% sont qualifiés pour le second
tour
mais alors qu'en est il des listes ayant
obtenu entre 5 et 10% et bien place aux
grandes négociations
ces listes ne sont pas forcément hors
course elles peuvent fusionner avec une
liste ayant fait plus de 10% pour
prétendre aller au second tour
c'est ce qu'on appelle la fusion des
listes cette fusion se fait d'un commun
accord et permet de cumuler plus de voix
en rassemblant parfois deux parties aux
idées proches qui se ressemble
s'assemble enfin c'est pas obligatoire
on +16 deux listes ont trouvé un terrain
d'entente
la fusion côte avoir lieu la liste ayant
obtenu entre 5 et 10% à playlist absorbé
peut ainsi placer quelques zones ses
moindres sur une liste ayant remporté au
moins 10% à playlist absorbante à
condition de respecter toujours la règle
de parité 1
cette nouvelle liste est ensuite déposée
en préfecture par le responsable de la
liste absorbante et ce au plus tard le
mardi 18 heures suivant le premier tour
jetez donc un petit coup d'oeil entre
deux tours au cas où il y aurait des
fusions sur ce je vous donne rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour un nouvel
épisode
et en attendant venez pas me poser vos
questions aux adresses ci-dessous
allez tiens